please welcome zack frass and donald
faison
[Applause]
thank you oh i'm so happy to
see you both i have like i've known you
and loved you for so long by the way
donald all my girls and i are watching
right now it's clueless so
nice to see you i love that that makes
my day right there drew yeah
it's true with my wife when i speak to
my wife later she
and she's and if i get on her nerves in
any way i'll be like well you know
drew watch is clueless so it's all good
and you know my i know you want to talk
to zach
i have so much to talk to you about you
both of you okay when i first moved to
los
angeles actually uh uh
breckenmeier paul rudd and alicia took
me out to
jones and we met you that night uh you
and uh and johnny from the karate kid
the bad guy from the karate kid and i
just
that's one of the highlights it was my
birthday it's one of the highlights of
uh
of my life wait a minute i had a hit
movie coming out i met you
and i got well i met you through brecken
meyer brecken was and every time i've
seen you since then i've always been
like
i know brecken
breckenmeier aka travis birkenstock was
like my
first boyfriend in like grade school wow
wow yeah
um i love bracken did you just say like
johnny aka william zabka from
karate kid and kobrakai was there
absolutely one of my favorite shows
ever paul was so excited it's the best
right thank you
get zach on board
well also like you know i'm sure that
everybody is talking about
a scrubs reboot and a scrubs
you know comeback and a scrubs movie i
know has been discussed
and it like dovetails perfectly into
your podcast zach
i mean i love you as a writer and a
filmmaker
and cobra kai did such an interesting
job like
rechecking back in do you ever
think of like how you would get back
into scrubs creatively not that you have
to spill the beans here but do you
ruminate
uh yeah well you know donald and i are
doing this podcast and
we you know we never thought it would be
this fun it was kind of uh it started
right before covid and it's just
exploded i mean it's it's it's it's
taken off like neither one of us could
have ever imagined and that's just been
thrilling and of course
the podcast has made us really want to
do more together
and and there's talk of of doing some
some sort of movie or something well
chemistry
is king i really believe that and you
guys
have it your real life friendship
translates
your chemistry like do you think that
that's the hook for
people and is it what makes it so fun
for you guys
that's the truth we get along so well we
just crack each other up and i think i
think we thought we did the podcast like
our parents would listen maybe a few
hardcore fans
and then little by little we do it
through i heart which
has zillions of podcasts and the guy
from my heart called us he's like you
have no idea what's happening
across the globe this has become it's
iheart's number one podcast
across the globe and they're like do you
guys you guys are at the level
of success like do you want to do like a
tour i was like oh my god we mean like
we could like
live the rock star life and get a tour
bus and go around they're like
absolutely
um so when kobe's over we're gonna like
tour
europe and like do the show live in
front of people guess what you're
already set up with all the merch
i just got this so that's you're halfway
there
with your tour and uh yeah we sent you a
onesie two that i really want you to
wear at some point
yes i'm uh i'm going to throw it on for
sure i just got it
i was texting drew and i said i sent you
a onesie and i expect to see you in that
one
and what's hilarious is i was like i
wonder if he's joking or not and i was
like okay no he wasn't
and i was like either way yeah of course
all right well guess
guess what who's gonna have this on when
we come back from commercial
yeah right for real maybe we'll see